The process of choosing a president formally begins with the primary election...
...when each party chooses a nominee.
During this process, each state holds its own vote called either a "primary" or a "caucus."
The first caucus is traditionally in Iowa.
In a caucus, citizens gather in a public space to debate issues and share concerns.
They then choose a candidate.
The results from each district are then tallied...
...to determine a statewide outcome.
The first primary is in New Hampshire.
A primary is like a regular election, where citizens cast ballots at a voting center.
One important date is "Super Tuesday," when lots of states vote on the same day.
These state primaries and caucuses then continue until around mid-year.
A winner usually emerges even before all the nominating contests are over.
But it's not official until later at each party's national political convention.